[Music]
on tv on radio and on your smartphone
this is talk tv
[Music]
i'm please morgana censored tonight
three big guests a ukraine check after
100 days of war this howland went as a
suffering stop ukraine's ambassador to
the uk will be with me
herod 30 the us defense chief who blitz
bin laden will be here to talk tough on
taking out tyrants
and beast lightning thunderbolt usain
the fastest man in history he'll be with
me too
you can finally catch up with me now
pierce i am both and i am uncensored
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well if one man knows all about
sacrifice mental resilience and winning
it's probably the fastest man in the
history of the world and in my opinion
the greatest athlete of all time usain
bolt won eight olympic gold medals he
holds a world record in the hundred and
two hundred meter sprints his blistering
9.58 second finish in 2009 remains
unassailed and his biggest achievement
of all i'm sure he would agree in his
most punishing assignment was that he
won soccer aide as captain in 2019 with
me as his manager and i inspired him to
score were you saying bolt returns to
the london stadium this sunday to lead
the world eleven at soccer it again for
unicef and i'm delighted to say you're
saying joins me now well skipper i i
still see you as my skipper how are you
i'm good i'm good pierce i'm good now
obviously you you don't have your
world-class coach with you this time so
how confident are you that you can win
without me
well i was planning to give you a call
get some tips just to make sure keep the
energy eye you know i mean ask you what
to tell the guys so
i just need that energy and i'm sure
we'll do well do you know what struck me
you say when i when i had the pleasure
of spending a few days with you on
soccer
i don't think i've ever seen anyone who
tried harder than you
to be brilliant at another sport
obviously you're the greatest athlete
you've ever lived but your dedication to
football
is extraordinary you really do love the
game don't you
yeah it definitely is a it's a it's a
sports that i really loved um coming up
um as a youngster and i watched as you
know i'm a manchester united supporter
so
i definitely keep abreast of what's
going on in the world when it comes to
football so when i play i do want to
play at my best
a good friend of mine is cristiano
ronaldo uh obviously at manchester
united again at the moment and you're
very similar characters in the sense i
think
at the core of your incredible success
the pair of you is a an almost
unbelievable mental strength and
resilience that goes with your talent
i mean do you think that without that
you would have achieved anything like
the success you've had
no i definitely think you have to be
resilient and and never give up you know
i mean you have to always want to do
more um
you have to never be satisfied and i
think that i agree with you i'm like
christine is like that he never gives up
no matter how much goals he scores he
wants to score more i was watching him
the other day and he scored two goal and
he missed one and he was so upset with
himself you know i mean he he just
always wants to do more and do better
and and that's the kind of mindset that
gets you to the top
and keeps you there yeah i completely
agree and i think itself it's a
self-fulfilling thing it's got to come
from within hasn't it because no one can
teach that to people i don't think
right i fully agree with this you can't
teach that you have to learn that from a
young age and
and just through growing up and wanting
something you know i mean you can't you
can't teach us because we have tried to
explain to young guys coming up which
you see at the talent and they don't
really understand you know i mean so for
me i think you have to have that mindset
and that drive to to want to be the best
and just want to be dominant could you
ever celebrate coming second you say
anything
no i feel like
no definitely not no
that's all you have to do is i'm a sore
loser i knew the answer but the great
champions are all sore losers aren't
they
you don't want to lose definitely
definitely
i want to talk to you no matter what
we're doing
yeah sorry yeah exactly yeah i want to
talk to you just about a few things that
are bubbling around the news which i was
really curious what your perspective
would be on it
the first one is the england football
manager gareth southgate came out a
couple of days ago and he was talking
about the euros final last year where a
young black player beca actually plays
for my team arsenal missed a penalty and
so did several other black players they
got abused uh racially abused because of
it by complete morons and southgate
actually said the other day that you
know it would make him think again in
future about whether he would let young
black players take penalties in that
kind of situation which i thought was an
incredibly dispiriting thing for him to
have to admit to what do you make what
do you make of that
that's that's tough to hear you know i
mean i've never i didn't hear this
comment but that's tough you know i mean
um
a lot of these guys they don't
understand the pressure
you know i mean standing in front of um
so many people in the weight of england
on your shoulder taking a penalty is no
joke and for somebody to say they
wouldn't give that person a chance
again to to prove themselves because
especially sakai is very young
he's new to it you know i mean it's hard
on the younger ones it's it's a learning
process you know i mean and he will get
better over the years so that's
that's tough to hear somebody said about
a black player
i think he did it from a kind of
protective viewpoint i mean he didn't
want to expose them
to abuse but i don't think you can take
that view can he
no i think you have to give her body a
chance you know i mean you have to give
that person a chance to
to be
himself you know i mean you learn from
your mistakes
and i'm sure you will learn from the
pressure and the more he plays football
the better you get so i feel like
everybody deserves a chance you know i
mean you should always give the person
the best player the chance to go and
prove himself and what advice you say
would you give to a young black athlete
sportsman whatever who's getting
racially abused on social media whatever
it may be
you must have had this i guess over the
years because twitter and so on is full
of complete idiots but yeah what would
your advice be to how to handle that
for me i stayed away from all
social media all media outlets i never
read the news pretty much so my
when i started out young
i i went through that a lot and i
figured out if if i don't read the
comments if i don't read the newspaper
if i don't watch the news then i won't
hear you know i mean my friends who are
close around me
um
they understand that they don't tell me
negative things
you know i mean so i just stayed away
from it you know i mean if you don't
read it if you don't listen to it you
won't hear so
i think that's very good advice the less
you read the better right and the purer
your head can be without this stuff in
your head
what a turn to the um
this whole issue of sport washing you've
got it with the golf uh stars at the
moment who decided to play in a saudi
arabian funded new tournament and it's
causing a huge furore but at the center
of it really is this question of whether
sports stars
should
have to be careful about countries they
align themselves with for sport i know
that you've i don't think you've ever
run competitively in saudi but you've
certainly done some work there speeches
and so on
i mean what's your view about this
where's is there a line that you
wouldn't cross
for me i think everybody is different
views are different in these in these
times now everything is different it's
hard to to say what's going to offend
people you know i mean and it's
it's really tricky right now i have a
team that
kind of try to protect me or try to make
sure we're on a straight line and to
make sure we don't
offend anybody as much as we possibly
can but it's it's tricky right now with
what's going on in the world with
everything you know you have to be very
careful with what you say and what you
do nowadays so it's just all about
understanding a situation
i mean i look at it and think there's a
lot of hypocrisy
amongst the criticism because if you had
the olympics in somewhere like china
uh and then i don't see an issue
particularly with golfers playing in a
saudi-sponsored golf tournament because
to me you either take a completely black
and white view of human rights records
of countries or you don't
yeah as i said it's it's all about
people look at things you know i mean
everybody has a different view
on everything this is why i stay away
from these things you know i mean
i again i have my team
i care for what i i say i just
try to stay focused on me and try to do
what i need to do to to stay
positive
what do you think of this issue you're
saying about trans athletes which is
obviously getting a lot of attention
at the moment a lot of people feel
it's unfair for trans athletes to
compete against women born to female
biological bodies you know we could have
a situation where if you wanted to
and you felt this way you could identify
as a woman and compete against women
would do you think that would be fair
reasonable
for me
i always say i'm not the person who
makes the rules you know i mean um even
when i was running and it was
the that i was asking about
drugs and who should be banned i always
say those are the rules i think a lot of
rules will be changed in the future and
it will be adjusted so
for me i just go along with the rules as
they are now
but do you think when you see what's
going on in swimming for example michael
phelps came out and said he didn't think
it was
fair would it be fair for for
sprinters who who've been born males to
then transition and compete against
women
well that's not for me to answer you
know i mean i think as again it's a
tricky situation
you know i mean it's for a discussion
and it's not for me to say you know i
mean it's it's up in here i would say
but in time as i said in times things
will change
um so just give it time and see where it
goes but just to clarify you're not
thinking of identifying as a woman any
time soon
no
no
you've got you've got three you've got
three kids you're saying um they've got
fantastic names olympian lightning bolt
thunderbolt and st leo bolt so they've
all they've all i would imagine got the
bolt sprinting gene who's the quickest
uh well right now olympia my daughter is
definitely showing um
that she wants to run she runs
everywhere she's always on her toes she
walks on her toes like a sprinter so
that's something that i look forward to
but my boys are just one so i'm keeping
an eye on them
do you forget i've spoken to racing
drivers jensen button told me every time
he goes out in a car on a on a normal
road there's always some bloke in a pool
she wants to try it on with him at a
traffic light and zoom off
to you as the fastest man to ever live
do you find that everywhere you go
there's always somebody who wants to
try and take you down and what do you do
about it all the time it's all the time
um
for the older people i just laugh but if
kids if they really want to try i'll
i'll race with them sometimes if i have
time on my hands
and sometimes i'll let them win if
there's a smaller kid but if bigger kids
i won't let them win
they've got to learn the hard way you
say that's how you learn how to win um
jamaica's going through
younger kids
sorry god
for younger kids it's it's it's it's
it's much more fun to let them win you
know i mean because they're really fans
and they look up to you but all the kids
understand that
it's not always going to be easy to win
you know i mean so i have to let them
know you have to earn this you have to
earn you have to earn the winning
because no you say all the kids will
brag well i never let any of my kids
beat me at anything uh the problem is
that three of them now got old enough
where they beat me at everything that's
the problem
but i think that's the winning mentality
i gave them gotta enjoy it
yeah you gotta enjoy it while it lasts
you know i mean
we just i definitely think i'll be that
dad also yeah exactly yeah we've just
had the the platinum jubilee for the
queen are you saying um i'm just curious
what do you think about jamaica jamaica
looks like it probably is gonna head
towards independence how do you feel
about that
for me
politics is not my thing if you if you
followed me throughout the years i've
always stayed away from politics
um because
politics is is all over the place you
know
they're against one day and then they're
with one day so for me i had to stay
away from it totally i have no comments
on that whatsoever have you ever thought
of being a diplomat you say
yeah just sometimes
[Laughter]
i've been i've been trying i've been
trying here
it was a fantastic experience it raises
a ton of money robbie williams who set
this thing up it's an amazing event
raises 10 11 12 million um and we had a
glorious win together and i'd like to
think that my pre-match team talk where
i i read churchill quotes to you all i
think that may have been the inspiration
can you can you confirm that
i'm just saying yes this is why i said
i'll make a call i'll we'll talk off
here you tell me exactly what to say and
i can
say to the guys in the in the locker
room you know i mean but i just want to
say to everybody no i mean go on
unicef website you know i mean
donating i mean um it's for a good cause
it's for vaccination uh to fight my
nourishment
and it's it's wonderful you know i mean
so just come out and support and just
give all donations are doubled so it
would be great well if you need any last
minute tips on how to win you're saying
you know where to come
definitely
best of luck a great thought to you
all right all right thank you very much
after the break with no end in sight to
the bloody war in ukraine is the only
solution to take out the narcissistic
bully at the kremlin former cia director
leon panetta who oversaw the operation
to bring down osama bin laden is
uncensored next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well we're not more than a hundred days
into the war in ukraine and the brutal
conflicts and danger of entering a
torturous and protracted stalemate the
uk is now warning the conflict could
last as long as a decade so a pause for
thought take a look at these five
pictures and ask yourself what links
them afghanistan yemen libya iraq syria
all devastating wars which cost
thousands of lives sparked humanitarian
disasters and also briefly commanded the
entire planet's attention
and then we moved on
so is ukraine now in danger be the next
that we simply move on from
it's what happens isn't it news moves on
politicians move on government
priorities change as voters fume about
problems closer to home especially with
surging inflation
but there's no end in sight for the
ukrainians the misery only continues
vladimir putin's force is now occupied
20 of the country and up to 100
ukrainians are dying every single day
and today the chilling news that two
british men and one moroccan national be
sentenced to death by pro-russian
officials they were captured fighting
with the ukrainian army in mariopol so
how do we end all this carnage this
genocide
how do we make sure the world doesn't
give up on ukraine which is exactly what
vladimir putin wants us to do well i'm
joined now by the ukrainian ambassador
to the uk vladimir psycho welcome
ambassador it's great to have you here
thank you
i get this awful feeling that the news
agenda which was so ukraine dominated is
beginning to move on a bit you know
people have their own crises at home and
so on and the hell for ukraine continues
what is your feeling about that what
more can we do to keep ukraine in
people's minds
frankly speaking i'm quite blessed here
in this particular capital in this
particular nation that is not this
process not that obvious but i agree
with you that's nature human nature news
nature government's nature to move on
another things because unfortunately
where there are so many of them so many
tragedies unfolding all over the globe
but we're trying to keep up this you
know the
news about ukraine on knowledge about
ukraine open for everybody here and i
have very receptive audience here
there are many ways that this war can
end
some are
not too bad for ukraine
notwithstanding what's already happened
some would be horrendous what is the
worst case scenario
as far as you're concerned was is what
putin wants he wants to reinstate
whatever government he wants and give he
wanted to get all over the this
territory he wants to get us back to the
stables of post-soviet republics some of
them he already has seen his stables now
here's the bigger bigger prize the
biggest prize probably out of all the
post soviet republics ukraine
president zielinski who appointed you to
your position uh only two years ago must
seem a very long time ago now that
you're appointed uh like i guess every
ambassador but um when he when he was
asked about boris johnson recently he
was extremely
uh
praiseworthy of both the prime minister
who's on a lot of domestic problems
obviously they're very praiseworthy of
him and of the government here in the
support that we have given to ukraine
who have been along with the uk
the best allies you've had and who needs
to do more
we have naturally lies like for example
poland
who understand us so so so closely
who've been through so many things with
russians over the history we have our
baltic republics all of three of them
who used to be in the same in the camp
of soviet union and they don't have to
tell them anything they know everything
and they know the price we have the
eastern europeans who are next to our
border they're supporting us because
they remember all these you know times
when the soviet union was coming with
the hard hands you know reversing what
sort of revolutions they had over the
years and years so these people
naturalize the people understand
obviously united states canada which is
very close to all ukrainian hearts there
are some couple of nations around the
globe
is putin the new hitler as far as you're
concerned personally i believe that he
is the closest one we can attribute to
hitler right now in this particular year
and if he prevails in ukraine do you
have any doubt that he will then try and
expand and invade other countries and
try and as he sees it restore the the
glory of the soviet union totally if you
feed the shark with hamburger it doesn't
mean they will have to have hamburger
each and every time next time they will
need a cow or something bigger and
ukrainian in comparison to what he had
transducerism on moldova some places in
georgia azerbaijani and in armenia now
he is coming for big and bigger price
and if he has ukraine with biggest by
territory in europe there's a huge
nation 40 plus million people if he has
it what will stop him for the next move
in europe do you think nato will they
have to sing
you must have a lot of family friends
back in ukraine it must be
a permanent worry for you how do how do
you deal with that being here in the uk
when all this is happening back home i
managed to get my nephews here because
their parents my brothers and his wife
today back in ukraine the police officer
she's just working there has to be there
so we take care of the kids i have my
mom i have my mom-in-law here so we
managed with the unkindness being
offered to us to bring them here to
allow them some safety are we doing
enough in this country to bring enough
ukrainians in fast enough
you're doing much but there is always
not enough when you have people waiting
on the bombardment for months for the
visa to to to appear in your magically
in your mailbox so this is very painful
but where we're working with your
government trying to resolve this when
we came on air two britons and the
moroccan man captured by russian forces
in ukraine to be sentenced to death what
is your reaction to that i had to react
today because i i was uh
meeting with the family or one of them i
actually met with all of them as two of
them were mentioned today and we are
trying to find finds in the answer how
these people can be so brave so patient
at the end of the days so encourage us
to to face this strategy
this this women where we are trying to
each and every day they would receive
the telephone call or video message from
them in captivity in this so-called
courts this is very difficult tragedy
the people strange but we have all now
almost four thousand people
and we consider your people your
nationals as parts of our armed forces
they're treated the same way they've
been useful for for the exchange the
same way they were trying to get them
out of there finally ambassador
president zielenski will speak uh at the
cambridge union uh tomorrow and i
believe other universities just quickly
tell me about that
this big gathering we have ukrainian
sort of students association which are
in all of these universities most of
those were very well known everywhere
around the globe not just here so he
will talk to the younger generation not
just britain ukrainians everybody who is
studied there and we hope that he will
be able to tell the new generation why
this war is relevant why this war
between uh and very old post-soviet
society as russia is now please tell
president zielenski we're huge admirers
of his in this country not that he
doesn't hear that from everyone but i
think he's a remarkable man doing a
remarkable job and we're all right
behind you ambassador thank you very
much for coming in thank you
well picking up on that now i'm joined
by the man who as director of the cia
oversaw the killing of osama bin laden
the former u.s defense secretary leon
panetta mr thank you so much for joining
peace morgana censored
good to be with you pierce
just discussing there with the
ambassador uh here in london about the
situation
in ukraine uh putin is slowly but surely
barreling his way through that country
what more should the world be doing to
try and stop him
well we're a hundred days into this war
uh we really have been through
what i call three stages of the war the
first was
a failed invasion by russia
uh the world stood up uh ukrainians
stood up and were able to
essentially stop the russians from
achieving their goal of getting the
capital and bringing ukraine down
the second stage is siege warfare and
tremendous destruction and killing of
innocent men women and children to try
to break the will of the ukrainian
people that failed as well
and the third stage is the one we're in
now which is this war of attrition
with russia trying to gain
uh territory in the east
in order to have leverage i assume for
negotiations
how long that war of attrition goes on
no one really knows it could continue
for weeks and months
uh it could result in negotiation which
is what the world obviously hopes for
or it could escalate
into something worse
the decision as to what happens
really rests with putin uh and nobody
else right now
henry kissinger suggested that ukraine
may have to see territory to end the war
the ukrainians obviously don't want to
do that
but is that something which perhaps
becomes inevitable the longer this goes
on
i think president biden was right in
saying that that decision has to rest
with ukraine uh and with zielinski
they're the ones that are fighting and
dying putting their lives on the line
every day in order to defend their
country
i think it's up to them to decide uh
what the basis of any possible
negotiation should be i don't think
anybody ought to tell them what they
should or should not do they're the ones
that have fought for the right to decide
what what will be on the table should
they negotiate
if you'd still be in defense secretary
or even running the cia you know
every sinew in my body
wants to attack vladimir putin to take
him on to kick him out of ukraine to use
the might of the nato military the most
powerful ever seen but he's been able to
so far successfully rattle his nuclear
saber as a kind of warning card to keep
people away
how long should we sustain that kind of
threat where he simply says if you do
anything
proactively here i will
nuke you
look i don't think we can be intimidated
by by putin
uh putin
has sensed weakness on the part of the
west for a long time that's why he went
into the crimea that's why he went into
syria and libya
and that's why he attacked this country
with a very bold cyber attack against
our election systems
because he sensed weakness
i think for the first time the united
states and our allies have come together
in a unified way
to say that uh putin will pay a price
for his aggression
uh and by providing uh the weapons
necessary for the ukrainians uh by
imposing the sanctions uh that uh are
really hitting the russian economy
seriously
uh and by re-strengthening our position
in the nato countries
i think the us and our allies
uh have done the right thing in trying
to stop putin
uh putin needs to be stopped bullies
need to be stopped
uh and the message that went to russia
is frankly the same message that needs
to go to china and north korea and iran
and other adversaries we have got to
come together as allies in order to stop
this kind of aggression
i want to pivot just uh briefly it's
over ten years incredibly since
osama bin laden was killed in that
remarkable raid you were immortalized in
a massively successful movie zero dark
30 played by james james gandalfini who
apparently had to
write to you before it even aired
apologizing for everything he said
including including his wig so i want to
play you a clip and then come for your
reaction
i'm about to go look the president in
the eye
than what i'd like to know no
it's where everyone stands on this thing
now
very simply
is he there or is he not in there
i gotta say i thought you came out of
that brilliantly and i don't know you
but if if i was you i would have loved
all that
well uh i remember when uh gandalfini
wrote me a note uh and said you know you
probably don't like the way i played
this role uh but i really admire you so
i called him up i met him at some events
uh and uh he said uh he said you know i
he said i i i hope uh i hope you like
the way i played it i said look i said
it's a movie i'm glad they picked an
italian to play in italian that that
made me feel good uh and he came back
and he said you know he said they made
me use a lot of four-letter words and i
said well you know that's the one thing
you got right
it's actually a great film i think the
the the best thing imaginable when
someone makes a big movie like that is
that it's good and i think not only was
it good but you had this amazing actor
playing you and i as i say i thought you
came out as badass mr panetta and that's
that's really how a former boss of the
cia wants to be right
well it was uh it was a tremendous
experience and i give a lot of credit to
both the military and intelligence
people for coming together working
together because that was the most
effective way to counter terrorism
did you still get uh just finally do you
still get people
thanking you personally when they see
you for taking out bin laden i think the
most rewarding thing that ever happens
to me is uh particularly when a family
of uh of those that were killed on 9 11
when members of that family see me and
thank me for
uh
for bringing justice
uh to uh to bin laden for what he did to
our country uh that's the most rewarding
feeling of law
well politicians get a lot of a a bad
rap over time but that was a stunning
a stunning moment i think for america
for that administration for you
personally and so you know
11 years on now isn't it um thank you
for what you did for the world because
you took out the worst terrorists in the
world that's got to be a good feeling
it was uh it was very important to send
a message to the world that nobody
attacks our country and gets away with
it uh and i was very proud of that
operation leo great to talk to you thank
you very much for being on the show
thank you
well school proms mark an emotional ride
of passage in any teenager's life but
this one's truly jaw-dropping the
graduating class of school 134 in hakeem
ukraine returned to the side of their
bombed out school for prom night marking
their final day at school by waltzing in
the rubble
[Music]
[Laughter]
well there you have it vladimir putin
the iris irrepressible spirit of these
remarkable ukrainian people alive and
well through to the next generations
defiantly dancing in the face of your
shameful onslaught an inspiration to
young people the world over and as leon
panetta said never ever give in to
bullies
on censored next tonight's peers pack
they're riled up ready and they're
coming soon there they are
what a pack
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well i have grave concerns about my next
story
yes if you sign up to study archaeology
you might expect to see bones right just
as training crime scene investigators
probably expect they may have to look at
pictures of crime scenes well apparently
not two british universities have
decided their courses should carry
trigger warnings for their simpering
snowflake students university of york is
now alerting aspiring archaeologists
that their course occasionally shows
images and videos of human remains well
yes that's the point of archaeology and
the university of exeter now warns
fledgling forensic scientists that crime
scene pictures may be offensive or
traumatic well yes that's what happens
if you want to be a forensic scientist
this is all obviously preposterous it's
like writing may contain nuts literally
on a bag of peanuts just wait until they
hear about biology
well fish and chips served by our local
chippy as we call it in the in the uk is
the taste of the british summer but this
year is the chippies themselves getting
battered russia's invasion of ukraine
has sent fuel and energy prices soaring
jacking up the cost of both the fishing
and the frying parts of the cod and
haddock are up 75 in the year sunflower
oil by 60 percent of flower prices by 40
tick tock has saved the day for one
fryer in coventry the binley mega chippy
has incredibly racked up millions of
views online after a catchy song about
the chippy went viral
[Music]
[Music]
it's sort of catchy i guess i'm joined
now by frank nakara whose family owns
the binli mega chimpy uh frank great to
talk to you um can i just ask you how
tough is it right now to be in your line
of work given these extraordinary
escalating prices
hi pierce how are you doing um it's uh
it's it's a very very difficult uh time
of
year and uh
it's with all the rising prices and the
war in in ukraine um it's very very
difficult to actually maintain
the margins and keep the staff on
without
to raise prices too much but we've
managed to balance it out really well
i mean what you've done brilliantly is
you've used tick-tock to turn yourselves
into a global phenomenon
well the viral uh jingle that you've
just been listening to uh thank you for
having done it but we've obviously
benefited a massive way from it um and
obviously we've set up our own accounts
obviously my account i'll put it on
little tick tock reels and some
instagram
and uh to push it even further to
gain more publicity and obviously it's
tv pressing interviews
but yes it's it's certainly helped and
helped
create a lot of business and uh for the
future as well if you could have a word
with boris johnson
the prime minister what would you most
want him to do right now for businesses
like you
take the v8 back to five percent that
would be a great help
yeah well good point we'll put it to him
if you have some the gumption to come on
the show i'll ask him uh frank good luck
to you i love i love the jingle i love
the business you're doing i love the
fact you're defying this you know near
recession now and doing a roaring trade
and next time i'm up there i'll come and
have a nice cotton ships with you
i wish you would and if i send you a
t-shirt this is all for charity we've
got something i've designed with me and
a supplier um
we're gonna we there's a website where
you can actually buy all our merchandise
this particular merchandise and every
single penny that we make from that
charity yeah i'll get a t-shirt to you
and a mug would you actually wear it on
your show i probably wouldn't wear it on
the show but i might do it for social
media for you just to try and capitalize
on your tick-tock fame frank good to
talk to you get back get back to work
thanks
thank you all experience take care yeah
well that's to you well john and esther
a bit of fun
oh hang on there's somebody at the door
oh my god
how often do you get stuck into two of
them these are very good they're local
are they healing right okay i have a tip
please tears just quickly your reaction
i mean
no get out of it
your tip is that you get to work with me
every day the
let me just ask you on a serious point
the amount these guys are having to pay
extra just in the last six months alone
because of inflation ukraine all these
things and post pandemic really tough
out there what did you think of his idea
of reducing v80
well i can understand why
it would help him but of course we have
already an enormous debt burden which we
accumulated during kovid and to ask the
chancellor to find a measure which would
cost an awful lot of money i i think
it's better to target the help on those
who really need it but i do want to say
one thing about what frank was saying
because frank is struggling
but there's behind the problems frank
facing is facing what i fear is going to
become a global crisis
because if you look at those parts of
the world that depend on ukraine for
their grain supplies for their oil
supplies potentially we are looking at a
humanitarian i completely agree i think
this is going completely unnoticed by
large swathes of people
is the the
what's going on in ukraine the
stranglehold they have on things like
flour oil
could be devastating in many parts of
the world yes let's do it hey criticism
no i know you're a fitness fanatic i
know i hope i've put back your regime um
just by a few weeks
what do you make though of of
yeah you got the fish and ship guy there
just a local business we were hearing
one of the crew actually his dad's new
working mission ship shops and three of
them have shut down in the last year and
this is devastating i mean so many shops
on my high street have shut down and i
see it all over the place you know and
you were saying that food prices are
increasing all over the world i believe
wheat prices um in egypt have gone about
250 percent can you imagine they're the
largest consumers of wheat in the world
and overnight the price they're paying
has gone up 250. the longer the wall
goes on the worse this is going to get
and there's 25 million tonnes of grain
sitting in the port of odessa and they
can't get it out and
knows all this yeah right so part of his
part of his strategy is to put a
stranglehold on energy and resources and
food because he knows eventually we may
have to wilt but we have to break the
gridlock right because we can't just
keep funneling money to this war that we
don't see an end in sight i think that's
a bigger problem as well because these
problems are just going to keep getting
worse and worse you know what there's a
lot of bad stuff going on there have
your fish and chips
and let's just try and enjoy at least
that that's it from me uh whatever
you're up to make sure it's uncensored
good night
[Music]
what was my biggest career moment after
spending about 25 years of fleet street
there's loads of stories i could tell
you but actually i think i did an
overnight show for tall radio in the
early days the night of the brexit
referendum and that was actually quite a
milestone because of course we started
off thinking um that remained at one and
at half past two four to three after
nigel farage had already said he'd lost
it turned out he hadn't lost but it
turned out we were leaving the european
union so that was quite shocking
[Music]
is talk tv news
good evening i'm zora zumerman the uk
has condemned the sham judgment after
two british men captured by russian
forces were sentenced to death aidan
aslan and sean pinner were detained in
april they're accused of being
mercenaries but their families insist
they were in ukraine's military
police searching for missing people in a
lake in devon have recovered two bodies
a boat capsized in the roadford lake
yesterday another person remains in a
critical condition
and in what's being described as a dark
day for drivers petrol has exceeded 100
pounds for the first time ever the prime
minister addressed the cost of living
crisis earlier today where he announced
plans to cut taxes and help people onto
the property ladder
well that's all for now we'll have more
after the talk
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you